je n'ai pas de cauchemars add on n'est
même pas dimanche je te dis tu veux me
dit truc tu atteindras toi ici n'ont
elles jamais atteint et c'est quoi tout
ce bruit on n'est pas trop mignon jean
meyer pour toi aussi et c'est aux
matelots quoi pas de bol souriez c'est
un beau sourire pour la photo
j'aime pas l'impression d'être faible
qui aimait gti team et gt line se marche
pas sur moi ici
soriano dit pas attendant pour château
[Musique]
préparer à voir leur famille s'agrandir
suppose sortie on te présente ton but
mais le bébé se préparer à autre chose
nous les bébés on est en pleine crise
les bébés ne reçoivent pas autant
d'amour qu'autrefois
je vous présente notre ennemi mortel le
bébé chien non vous voyez c'est ça le
problème
vous avez appris quelque chose ninon
avez vous des infos sur les bébés chiens
gentils bébé sinon jimbo les bébés
chiens sont démoniaques stacy re lisez
moi vos notes
je ne sais pas me dire qu'est ce que ça
dit bonjour on dirait qu'ils sont à leur
petite table de réunion ghsr
c'est atrocement humiliant je suis le
bébé qui vous font pour ce club je sais
que cette mission est capitale pour la
société messieurs caca prout que je
m'occupe du ga emilienne wiki et je suis
chargé de mission il n'y a pas assez
d'amour pour tout le monde
mon boulot c'est le trouvais pourquoi on
cherchait un double expresso et voici à
des bons sushis dans le quartier je
tuerai pour un rouleau de ton tataki au
sésame
la guerre est déclarée
lâchage papa tu regardes les enfants ont
fini par s'entendre c'est formidable si
je loupe cette mission il faudra que je
vive avec toi pour toujours
ok je te donne un coup de main mais
seulement si tu fiche le camp après ça
roule
voilà le petit train qui arrive quand il
regarde hockey prend ça dans le tube
fait pour passer devant le tarn
je n'ai jamais connu une telle
humiliation de toute ma vie
[Musique]
je mettrai pas le costume de marin petit
mâle m pourquoi t'as qu'à la lumière
qu'est ce que c'est tout ce bruit vous
avez vu comme il est mignon
j'en ai apportera aussi quoi paul
dreamworks baby boss pose ce biscuit
tout de suite les biscuits c'est pour
les gagnants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]